yes I keep the mic in nice and close
okay well welcome back to an episode of
mlst gogglebox the monk debate special
edition and I'm here with my good friend
David Foster David introduce yourself
yeah great to be back again Tim thanks
for having me on um so yeah I'm David
Foster I'm co-founder of a company
called applied data science Partners uh
we're an AI consultancy here based in
London I'm also the author of a book
called generative deep learning which
came out first of all in 2019 and the
second edition has just been published
about a month ago
um so yeah I'm obviously really excited
to see the applications of generative AI
both commercially
um but also you know to see how it's now
driving the debate around things like
artificial general intelligence and
existential risk
um so yeah really excited to see the
monk debate the other day come out
because I think you know a lot of the
Technologies they're talking about there
are ultimately generative AI That's what
sparked all of this new excitement about
the field
now we're going to actually watch the
monk debate with you and we're going to
give you a rolling commentary um but
just before we do that first of all
David you've got a podcast that you've
just launched as well do you want to
just plug that yeah sure it's called the
AI canvas and it's basically a podcast
where we talk to people who are going to
be impacted by things like generative AI
but don't necessarily have a background
in the field because I think a missing
part of the conversation actually these
days is speaking to people who are kind
of aware that this technology is here
and it's in the public eye obviously a
lot you know these days but aren't
necessarily the ones who are going to be
building the models but are going to be
using them so we're talking to teachers
we're talking to lawyers we're talking
to people in education sector and we're
talking to people in marketing just
people who I like seriously worried like
photographers anybody who you know is
thinking to themselves maybe I should
actually pay attention to this
technology and we just have a very open
and honest discussion about what it's
capable of doing what it's not capable
of doing
um and so hopefully people can find
interest in this because it's a
different angle that they might not you
know hear about through
um through other means so that's the
that's what it's called AI canvas
amazing amazing okay so um this month
debate it's been shared everywhere on
Twitter and uh it had Jan the [__] and
Melanie Mitchell uh Melanie's my
favorite person in the whole world on
the on the con side and um on the pro
side was uh Max tegmark and um my mind's
blanking uh Joshua and Joshua benjam
yeah sorry Joshua so um high level
thoughts before we roll into it right so
high level thoughts I really enjoyed the
debate I thought it's obviously a debate
that needs to happen uh there's
obviously a real split in the community
at the moment so to get such prominent
figures talking about this openly and
having a a very um honest and Frank
debate is certainly what's needed
um I think if I were to sort of Briefly
summarize both positions I would say the
X risk side often comes at this from a
perspective of exponential growth and
the fact that you know we've developed
Technologies all through our existence
that have in some way been able to cause
harm but the idea that this technology
might be the one that actually tips the
overs the edge to existential risk and
so that certainly Max tegmark's opinion
and then on the other side you have you
know people like lacun and Melanie
Mitchell saying well you know first of
all there's not actually a guarantee
that any of this that we're building is
first of all an existential risk we need
to go far more into the detail and
there's missing parts in the words of um
janakun but also to say like we also
need to kind of have this very open
discussion about what exactly we mean by
intelligence and smartness you know we
hear words like super intelligent so
it's going to be smarter than us
really used quite quite um broadly and
very in a way that kind of doesn't
actually offer much I think to the
debate because it's surely a definition
of these terms is essentially
essentially if we're going to be
actually talking about these as uh
potentially causing us harm we need to
understand why and what the mechanism is
what's the specifics of the situation
that does so
um so I thought whilst the debate was
was good and we heard certainly that the
broad brush Strokes on both sides I
think it could have also gone into
detail but maybe that's what we can do
today in this discussion yeah um
completely agree so we'll talk about the
mechanism point in detail later but as
you say with every other existential
threat the the why the mechanism is laid
out clearly it's understood it's known
whereas in this particular example it's
not known and when you try and press
them on the mechanism like what is
intelligence they they're not having any
of it so we'll talk about that as we go
through so um in which case we're going
to press the play button and gogglebox
gogglebox will will continue
technology
can be used for good and for bad and its
power is growing exponentially
which means of course that it's blast
radius you know the amount of damage it
can do to our society is also growing
exponentially back in the Stone Age with
Iraq maybe someone could kill five
people
300 years ago with a bomb maybe a
hundred people
in 1945 with a couple nukes 250
000 people with bio weapons even more
with nuclear Winter According to a
recent science article
over 5 billion people so now the blast
radius has risen
up to about 60 percent of humanity
and since as we'll argue superhuman
intelligence is way going to be way more
powerful than any of this
its blast radius can easily be a hundred
percent of humanity giving it the
potential power to really wipe us out
now to stir things up to have a tweak
here from my friend John lacun who says
that making AI safe
is going to happen as with every new
tech and it's going to be a process of
iterative refinement now I think
iterative refinement is great for less
powerful technology like jet engines and
and less powerful AI well you have the
luxury of trying many times but I think
it's a terrible strategy when you're
talking about things as powerful as as
nuclear winter or some future AI that we
could completely lose control over
because then you really only get one
chance
you have to get it right the first time
and can't come back in iteratively
refine now why is it
that superhuman AI
can be so much more powerful than all
those other Technologies it's because by
definition
it can do all the intelligent things the
way humans can do just better
for example it can do goal-oriented
Behavior it can persuade manipulate hire
people start companies build robots do
scientific research
it could for example research how to
make more powerful bio weapons
or how to make even more intelligent
systems so it could recursively
self-improve itself it also
could do things that humans cannot do at
all it could very easily make copies of
itself so if you imagine for a moment a
um
super you and AI that can think I feel
like we we need to press pause here
before I
um forget half of the points that he's
made so he's talking about iterative
Improvement does not work for Dangerous
technology he asserted that this
technology can already do science I
don't think it can and he asserted that
recursive self-improvement is a problem
and he asserted that this technology has
a blast radius that's greater than the
world we live on so let's touch on some
of those yeah so I think firstly if you
look at that charts I think there's a
there's actually a case to be said here
about comparing apples with oranges
because if you look at the early things
that he's putting up there things like
rocks bombs nukes bio weapons these all
have physical impact in the world the
entity themselves is the thing that's
causing the damage to then you know
write AGI as the last Point AGI in
itself is more akin to human it's like
you you draw this chart and then at the
last point you put human and it's like
the human itself is just something that
has the potential to use these other
Technologies so I think it's it's
firstly a fallacy to draw a chart where
the final point on this curve of things
that cause physical harm in the world is
Agi because AGI itself isn't the risk
what he's trying to say is that it has
the potential to use other technologies
that do create
um physical harm in the world so I think
you know first of all there's something
to be said here around there's a missing
gap between you know saying
um AGI has the potential to use all of
these physically harmful Technologies or
is he saying that the entity itself is
something that we should fear in its own
right you know because it has the
potential to be embodied and actually go
around actually causing physical harm
itself
um so I think that's the first point to
note that uh I think it's worth
mentioning just just before we move on
to the second point I think we should
touch on this substrate thing so
in in a sense we are increasingly living
in the informational substrate anyway
and philosophers have said that's our
main nature of existence there's a
digital divide our children live almost
entirely in the digital substrate and
therefore if there was a nuclear bomb in
the digital substrate that would
actually cause harm potentially
um or not depending on how you look at
it but um what do you think about that
kind of Gap in in where we live
well yeah I mean there's there's always
going to be technologies that cause
so-called explosions in the digital
substrate I mean you could say the same
thing about computers themselves or
um the very fact the internet came along
was an absolute explosion of how we
interact digitally so I think just to
say you know another technology that is
um able to to do things in the digital
substrate that we currently can't
imagine is an existential threat is a
huge leap to make and I would still
argue that for something to really be
talked about seriously as an existential
threat it needs to have a very concrete
mechanism that we can all understand and
describe that allows us to go from the
point of it existing to oh suddenly
humans are all under threat and I think
what a lot of the xai
um existential threats AI people are
saying is that you know we used to treat
AGI as a kind of threat in the same way
that we treated aliens as a threat
noblem can precisely explain the
mechanism through which the threat will
be realized but of course there's a
non-zero probability that something
might happen
and I think before you know the GPT
Revolution
people would have said the same thing
about you know super intelligent AGI and
we're talking about the Sci-Fi kind of
Terminator movie sort of style
um but what they're claiming here is
that we need to start we need to move it
from this area of unfounded and and
where the mechanism is not clear across
to other kinds of existential threat
like nuclear weapons or biohazards and
bio threats where there is a I could
explain to you from a physical
perspective
um the mechanism through which this this
thing that exists in the world will
cause a serious harm if we do something
really bad with it
um so what I I would love to hear is
somebody that's skeptical is what that
mechanism is precisely not just you know
big statements like recursion it's going
to build robots I want to know the
physical process through which that
happens because I could certainly
explain that to you um with regards to
nuclear warheads for example I could
tell you the precise sequence of events
that would happen that could lead to one
of these things exploding and causing
huge amounts of physical harm I could do
the same thing with passage at pathogen
release I could do the same thing with
an asteroid impact you can explain these
things precisely and so no matter what
side of the debate you're on and whether
you think it's um you know a 10 risk or
a naught point no no one percent risk at
least we can talk about the same
mechanism
um and and we can talk about the steps
of that mechanism in a way that actually
allows us to make progress with the the
debate because I feel a lot of the
debate is so high level that it's
actually really difficult to
put a pin on and say this is the step
that I disagree with you about you know
we need to move the debate on from just
saying you know AGI is going to build
robots that wipe us out yeah I mean two
things on that I think you and I both
agree that the mechanism is the single
most important factor in The credibility
of an existential risk argument we
should um just quickly touch on what we
mean by existential by the way
um when there's a um a housing market
crash in the UK it doesn't mean a crash
even in the Great Depression it wasn't a
total crash the housing market crash I
think is around 10 or something like
that so it's not entirely clear whether
they mean 10 of humans will die or All
Humans will die
um on the macro scale even if nearly all
of us died Humanity would recover and be
just fine and weirdly an exit you know
like with World War II we have mutually
assured destruction but also just the
fact that we had such a cataclysmic War
kind of prevents it from happening again
so like sometimes weird things happen
and if we were nearly wiped out that
might actually prevents us from making
the same mistake again but anyway coming
back to this mechanism thing
knowing a mechanism makes it more
credible and the reason why we need to
have a credibility filter is I believe
that there are an infinite number of
possible existential threats and just
being able to do the what about ISM and
say oh it could do this oh it could have
instrumental goals oh it could blah blah
blah
um I can pick from an infinite set of
possible scenarios that would fit that
criteria so I'm not saying that it's not
possible I'm just saying it's not
credible yep so yeah there's that and
also there's this interesting thing that
you were just alluding to which is that
the risk people
um have all of these concentric circles
and different angles and they avoid
talking about the mechanism but they
also have a progressive disclosure of
complexity and domain and actually it
gracefully degrades all the way down to
the AI ethics discussion which means
they can kind of say well you know it
also could be used for aligning current
threats but I think it makes it quite
slippery because we'll talk about some
papers that we've looked at recently and
they're they're talking about very
um realistic plausible things you know
like the the bio risk for example and
and um you know that that's a bit of a
concern for me because it's so nebulous
and amorphous they can never lose in a
debate and also there's a real moral
component to it which is that they'll
always just say oh but we're all going
to die are you a bad person or um you
know I don't want my mum to die and I
don't I don't want to say it's a moral
panic but it's kind of like the Joker in
the pack that they pull out if they feel
they're losing the argument sure yeah
and I think as well it's it's important
to know you know for a debate like this
where the motion is is it an existential
threat or not all that the pro side
needs to do is get the console to agree
that that's non-zero and I feel debates
like this don't really help us to really
get to the heart of the matter because
you could probably put a non-zero
probability against a lot of stuff that
we don't currently mitigate for Alien
Invasion etc etc
um so you know what we need to discuss
isn't necessarily like just trying to
get the other side to say black and
white statements like I don't think this
is at all and existential risk but we
need to start sort of actually going
down into the detail and saying like how
far away are we from these really
important pieces of the puzzle that are
currently missing
um you know so we we hear about like
that that AGI is going to in future be
able to
um to do things like build versions of
itself and so okay like we can take that
as an idea and if that's what we're
really worried about here we can talk
about things like okay do we mean
physically be able to create its own
server do we mean or do we mean using
other human servers and being able to
move itself because there's differences
there and I think what the impression I
get with a lot of the arguments is that
at a broad level the s x risk arguments
sound extremely plausible but if you
zoom in like and you look at under the
microscope you realize that there's
brittleness to everything and and that
when you start to actually narrow down
exactly what the concern is you start
thinking well there's a ton of
complexity around that that we just
don't know about like you know an AGI
being able to
to create its own architecture is
something that I'm literally hearing
people talk about as a realistic
possibility yeah but to do that
you know how does it how does it pull
all those components together are we
talking about the AGI manipulating
humans to do this in which case you know
why would those humans continue to do
something for an AGI system
um when they know it's something that
isn't aligned to a particular person why
um you know in the case of that you know
if they've been able to
um to do things in the physical world I
often hear the argument that well you
know humans can go to the moon and Jim's
car and there's a three times and you
have three times brain size but then I'd
ask well how would AGI get to the moon
how would AGI move itself to the Moon
can it you you really arguing that you
think it's going to be able to do that
itself without any human input and so
there's a there's a gap there I think
between you know what are we actually
talking about when we're saying AGI is
smarter than us and it's about what do
we Define the smart to be
um for me smartness is inextricably
linked to the ability to manipulate the
physical world because I think you know
I honestly think that if you look at
what humans are capable of doing it's
not just what goes on in our brain and
what we can achieve as a language model
if you like but also the fact that we
have
um we have dominion over the physical
world using things like our hands and
our feet that allow us to be extremely
flexible to a number of different
environments and create using raw
materials something that is is new and
hasn't ever happened hasn't been created
before and I don't think
I think robotics obviously is lagging
hugely behind AI at the moment with
regards to the ability for robots to
actually exist and be robust
um animals and you know even things that
we would considered to be not that
intelligent are amazingly robust to
their environment and you know you
mentioned earlier the kind of the idea
that maybe AJR will just cause
explosions in digital substrate but I
think these are all things that
ultimately a human Creations are in the
first place so
you know if we if we just talk about AGI
as being something that might affect us
digitally I feel we're we're miles away
from now the existential topic of the
entire debate you know this is something
I don't think will ultimately cause us
as a society to
um to suffer in the way that you know
something like a nuclear warhead would
be yeah it's very different yeah and I
completely agree with that and and um
I'm interested in an activism which is
this idea as you were saying it's it's
very closely related to embodiment that
minds are embodied actions and like one
way to think about it is the the the
world we live in is a computer so it's
not just about our minds it's about us
taking actions in in the real world and
actually one of the early proponents of
this for assist uh Francisco Varela
doing that early cyberneticist
um I discovered from my friend Mark
Bishop the other day that he's actually
an ID list which surprised me a little
bit so it's this um thread of philosophy
that basically says in a sense the only
substrate is um mind and the physical
world doesn't even exist so it's almost
like a another form of you know
information on substrate and pure play
idealism is is when um in a sense your
your own subjective experience is just
in your mind and and you know and and
different in your mind and the manual
Kent had this transcendental version
where they were objectively Linked In in
some sense but
um yeah so I guess the discussion we're
making here is about traversing
different substrates so there's the
material physical substrate there might
be a substrate that's just in your mind
or there could be some kind of shared
informational substrate and what happens
if you drop nuclear bombs in any one you
know any one of those substrates but
anyway enough of the philosophy because
we can go we can go um crazy on that so
let's let's carry on I think 10 say a
thousand times faster than the human
researcher so it's in the nine hours do
years worth of research but now instead
think of a million of those a swarm of a
million super intelligent AIS
where as soon as one of them discovers
something new it can instantly share
that new skill with all of them that's
the kind of power we're talking about
here and finally
superhuman animal probably be a very
alien kind of intelligence that lacks
anything like human emotions or empathy
so of course it would have the power and
potential to wipe us out if it had those
goals but
why would it possibly have those goals
next slide please
well
one the most talked about way in which
this could happen is if we've given it
some sort of goal that it actually
Faithfully obeys but that goal list
isn't fully aligned with with human
goals this is uh the way we humans have
usually wiped out other species
for example when we wiped out this this
uh guy here the West African black rhino
you know it wasn't that we hated
rhinoceroses and we're deliberately
trying to kill them it's just that some
some humans had this weird goal that
they thought that if they eighth ground
the Rhino horn their sex life was going
to get better even though this was
totally debunked in the medical
literature but the humans were smarter
than the rhinos and the so it was the
human's goals that prevailed or if you
chop down the rainforest for the goal of
making money you know and you extinct
the species that was living there
another example of
what could happen to us if it's Rogue AI
at the top here we have a second route
to Extinction which could be malicious
use
so to stir things up more have another
tweet from Jan where you see he says we
would have obviously never designed AIS
to have that sort of goals
but who is we
I'm sure you wouldn't Ron wouldn't do it
because I know personally he's a very
nice guy and to you in the audience it
might seem really weird that anyone
would do it because you're all so nice
because you're Canadian but in the U.S
we should take a tiny pause there so he
said a couple of interesting things
first of all he made a similar comment
to Hinton which is that
all of these skills will be acquired and
then they'll be shared into the central
Nexus and also I can appreciate why they
might think that when you have loads of
AIS all over the world it's a bit like a
search process so discovering new skills
it gets Acquired and assimilated into
the Nexus and this thing will just
exponentially increase in capability and
it comes back to what we were saying
about whether these things can do
science it's it's all about whether it
can actually create breakthroughs based
on the kind of the manifold or the space
that already exists I think it doesn't
and this is what Grady butcher was
talking about and I think a lot of
people with respect don't understand
what abduction is because abduction is
one of the core tenets of intelligence
in my opinion it's it's all about
creating a plausible hypothesis space
it's a very creative process it's
something that we do when we have a
flash of inspiration and also from an
embodied point of view much of that
inspiration might be determined by the
physical location that we're in which
makes it even more difficult to
replicate in in silico so yeah that that
is what makes a truly creative process
so I think even if you did have loads of
Agents around the world you know running
track GPT it's not actually going to
make those scientific uh breakthroughs
yeah there's two points maybe I can pull
out here as well so one is around
um you might you'll obviously be
familiar with The Arc challenge of
Francois surely yes um the idea and this
is for listeners this is a challenge
that he created which basically showed
we're quite far away from creating an
intelligence that we as humans
inherently seem to have and we don't
really understand why the challenge
centers around
um almost like a series of IQ style
puzzles where you have to say
um you know if this relates to this in
this way and you give you you're even
maybe a few examples of this how does
this image transform into the the answer
now people were sort of seeing this
problem and thinking like well you know
it's very easy for us to do but maybe we
should just throw things like um you
know GPT 4 at it and it will be able to
solve up no problem and actually I
haven't seen so only any progress made
on the arc challenge as a result of all
of this AI Revolution that we're
currently going through so there seems
to be some form of intelligence that
even at scale as you know techmark is
saying here it's not just a case of
throwing more compute at it and building
up skills there's a missing piece of the
puzzle here that we just don't have and
if if you know what he's saying is
accurate then surely we would have seen
this happen already somebody would have
just solved Arc by throwing tons of gpt4
replicas at it the other one I think is
an interesting thought experiment to
explore
is whether
um a large language model trained on
data up until a certain point in history
would be able to make scientific
breakthroughs from that point onwards
and when we were talking about earlier
was general relativity is it's a perfect
example of a seemingly extrapolative
Insight that Einstein had that takes us
from the point of thinking that time is
absolute to time is not absolute and it
depends on the Observer now I would
argue that even our most powerful and
future versions of things like you know
GPT are not going to be able to make
that seemingly extrapolated link between
um the stuff that they've been trained
on where everything is telling us about
Newton's laws of motion and how those
are absolute and fundamental through to
holding those ideas in disbelief even
temporarily in order to go and make the
logical conclusions that Einstein made
um I think there's too strong a prior on
the data set and I can't see how it's
going to be able to
to make logical leaps to the point where
it's going to actually say everything
I've been trained on is wrong yes so so
where does that come from and I've never
heard an argument counter to that that
I've been convinced by yeah and the the
beautiful words that came out of your
mouth is there's too strong a prior and
that's how these statistical models work
they have to have priors because there's
an exponential amount of possible
combinations so you have to have a cone
of attention now you can argue with
Einstein that the macroscopic concepts
already existed in our physical world I
mean what he did was he looked at
ripples on a pond right and so you could
say that well GPT already understand you
know probably macroscopic Concepts that
we already know will lead to scientific
breakthrough so it's not just about
acquiring the concepts empirically but
it's also about this process of
abduction which is taking this
exponential number of combinations and
kind of bringing them together and the
other thing is well if they're making
the argument that you know if that
ability really existed I could
understand I mean I would would be on
techmark's side if I thought that that
kind of abduction was possible that
ability to create those abductive
inferences from empirical data
efficiently I would be worried as well
the reason why I think we're making the
counter argument is that we're we don't
think that's possible and also beautiful
point about Francois Charlotte so um for
folks who don't know about Francois
chalet's argument about intelligence
he's basically saying that it's about
the conversion ratio between
um your experiences and and your prayers
so what you already know and being able
to create new skill programs that can
respond to novel future situations so
it's literally a ratio between this blob
that you already have and how quickly
can I expand the surface area now he
would argue correctly that language
models already have a huge surface area
because they've already Incorporated all
of the information in in the world and
every time they create a new program
they're just like microscopically
increasing the surface area they're not
making those big jumps because if they
did they would actually be intelligent
yeah exactly and you know I think it's
really interesting I mean I'm sure there
are people actively working on this idea
of you know being able to solve
challenges like Arc using large language
models but my understanding at the
moment is that the current state of the
art on the challenge is around 35
accuracy and that it's basically just a
large set of rules that are being
applied there's even fundamentally no AI
um at all so
uh yeah you know what's missing here I'd
love to hear kind of the argument from
the other side of yeah I think we can
kind of get to the point you know I
think the interesting thing about this
thought experiment with Einstein it
doesn't have to be a thought experiment
let's go and build that large language
model um let's take a cut-off point and
say we're not going to include anything
in the training set and after this point
and and let's explore some of the
fundamental
um uh advancements to science that we
made you know DNA or
um yeah general relativity or quantum
mechanics and let's see how far it gets
to to really helping us to understand
those problems yeah um I would love an
institution out there to build a large
language model on data trained up until
a certain point in history and see we
can run that validation set can't we and
see what happens and then and quite
often Conor says something along the
lines of what's the least impressive
capability that would make you update
that's it right yeah that's it for both
of us that would certainly be an
experiment I'd love to see run and also
like to see progress in Arc as well I
think that would be something I'd you
know I'd to be clear I'm very open to
changing my mind on these things and
yeah I think um yeah it's Bertram
Russell isn't it that said if the facts
change I changed my mind so I think it's
a good uh certainly a good um you know
thing to live by from both sides of the
argument as well I hope that would come
from the x-rays side as well yeah 100
and also I just wanted to touch on this
um this slide from techmark
um
maybe we can go back but it was a great
example of this Progressive disclosure
of complexity that I was talking about
so he's saying
um you know we've got a rogue AI so
that's the Fringe thing we've got AI
which is going to recursively
self-improve and take over the world and
have instrumental goals and he's kind of
like um uh placating the the less wrong
school of thought there and then he's
also like having another concentric
Circle which is applying to the moderate
saying oh but it could there could be a
malicious Ai and people will resonate
with that oh you know so bad humans you
don't you think all humans are good but
there are bad humans who are going to
use it maliciously and that's kind of
hedging almost uh intersecting with the
original AI ethics type claims so
they're kind of capturing all of the
bases there yeah exactly and I think
it's very useful when having these
discussions to narrow down to a
particular type of AGI risk you know
it's different to say the AGI itself is
going to run away and start doing things
of its own malicious intent it's also a
very different thing to then say well it
was origin can be given a human
malign prompt that it goes and runs away
with it's a completely different
argument to then say actually this thing
is going to be completely
um you know benign of its own accord and
that actually
um it's going to be humans that use it
in bad ways so you know to frame the
discussion and just say AGI is an
existential risk is so broad that you
you make no progress on debates I think
if you keep it at that level but if we
say okay we're going to talk about
specifically the the use case where
um you know it's in the world and some
malicious actor has the ability to use
AGI to to to effectively wipe everybody
out so that that's a real thing we can
now start to make progress on forget the
idea that you know AGI is going to have
its own goals and come up with its own
um you know opinions about wanting to
get to the moon we're talking about
something specific now and then we can
dive into the detail further and put it
under the microscope
um but it's too often just left at such
a high level that you know no progress
gets made
cool we regularly have mass shootings
where people deliberately try to kill as
many people as possible so if if there's
some sort of super powerful open source
AI you know a person who wants to kill
as many as possible might well use that
and the AI is safe in the sense that
it's totally obeying its owner now right
still causes disaster the Third
route to disaster right place here is
just that we get out competed this is
the one that's the least discussed and I
would love to hear from John and Melanie
what their plan is to avoid the one in
the middle
and the one at the top so out competed
well by definition AI can do if it's
superhuman all our jobs better right so
companies that replace the humans that
don't replace their humans by AI well
get out competed by those who do
similarly it's about delegating not just
jobs but also decisions so companies
that don't have an AI CEO will be out
competed by those who do militaries that
don't have ai generals will be out
competed by militaries who do countries
that don't have ai government will be
out competed by countries who do and we
end up in a situation where we humans
have quite voluntarily just given away
more and more power to Ai and we yeah
this is really interesting this is
something I can get on board with it's
something that Daniel Dennett said which
is that the real threat of language
models is the erosion of our autonomy
um and it will kind of create a passive
Society where we acquiesce to the AIS
and I was in Zurich last week speaking
with Yannick and he actually said that
he loved this idea he said that he
didn't have an authority problem he had
a trust problem he said in many ways
having this kind of omnipotent AI which
made fair and rational decisions you
know he had to get on board with that
which I was very surprised about but
also the the way this is always framed
is that there's going to be some Global
AI Nexus centrally making all of the
decisions right and surely there's going
to be millions of AIS competing of each
other I guess that's an unfair
representation he said that they'll be
AI CEOs and so on
um is that necessarily a bad thing if it
leads to more market value uh yeah look
I mean so you know his argument here is
that
um you know AI is going to be something
that some people have and some people
don't have and therefore it creates
Division and my argument to this would
be well I think you could say the same
thing about any technology that gets
released into the world and you know you
could say the same thing about
militaries with Advanced Computing and
militaries without advanced Computing
um yeah of course like there's going to
be there's going to be Division and
there's going to be
um a range of capability
um but I I don't think that the argument
particularly holds where to say well
that in itself is enough to kind of say
well we shouldn't do it
um
you know I so yeah I'm all on board with
regulation and I I generally aren't you
know believe that there needs to be some
form of a discussion at the highest
level around how we how we regulate this
technology because the way I sort of see
it is a lot of the rules that we've
written in laws are assuming and on the
very
um grounded assumption that these will
be applicable to humans only in future
um and that actually what will need to
happen is that we'll need to understand
that there might be entities in the
world that are taking decisions that we
considered previously to be just
human-led but have never seen a human
ever in that Loop so then from a legal
perspective I think the question becomes
where does the responsibility lie and
you know should it be on the the owner
of the system to make sure that whatever
is being built is
um is is ultimately
um under the same laws that a human
would be who was making the same
decisions about that particular domain
um but I don't think I'm also Less on
board with the idea that the the the the
training and building of the models
themselves should be regulated because
then it becomes a bit like saying
you know your python thing that you're
writing should only be able to run on X
number of gpus and it just becomes a bit
silly and I think the regulation if
anything should apply to use of
Technology rather than
should we even create this stuff in the
first place
um I just don't think it's first of all
able to be actually implemented at such
a broad level again you know why why
would you restrict just to AGI why not
say any program that you write should
actually only be able to be run on
certain amounts of limited compute where
do you draw the line even between
something that's artificial intelligence
and not so yeah you start to get into
all sorts of fallacies and complexities
like that
um but that you know we of course we
need to be able to say legally things
like if you have an AGI system you can't
just connect it directly to a nuclear
weapon and let it make decisions about
when to
um but you know we already have this we
already have mechanisms in place to make
sure the things that can do a serious
harm there is a huge amount of sign off
that needs to go into
um being able to access things like a
particular pathogen or a particular
weapon or a particular you know and it's
not just a single point of failure there
are multiple humans involved
um and and so maybe the law and
regulation in future needs to say that
you can't put in charge you know these
systems in charge of things without any
human oversight and that that always has
to be human in the loop and it's not
something we've ever needed to consider
before because we've never had a case
where a human wouldn't be in the loop
because that's all there's the only
intelligence we've got
um so yeah I you know I take his point
that you know that there might be
differences in future between some
countries and others or some entities or
institutions but that's not absolutely
not a reason not to build it yeah and
you made a great point about there being
you know not being a bright line and I'm
a gradualist bit like Dennis I think
that there is no bright line between
narrow intelligence and Broad
intelligence and I would also like to
think that it's a far more gradual
process of evolution and I can
understand why tegmark thinks that it
could just exponentially change society
I mean if you look at Evolution you look
at just human development on this planet
in the context of the lifetime of of of
the planet it does look like a stark
transient change and and I can
appreciate why they might
um argue for that I also wanted to make
an interesting point about
um existential threat to humanity could
also be an existential threat to
capitalism because I used to watch some
leftist films when I was younger and
they were basically advocating for a
form of neo-marxism which is you know
kind of like Marxism with machines where
we don't need to do the drudgery of
working every day and we've got some
centralized Nexus making all of the best
decisions for us and it kind of frees us
up and liberates us to um you know kind
of explore our Humanity in ways we
currently can't and that is a bit of an
ideological divide because a lot of
people would completely hate that idea
yeah and I think take them up mentions
it is closing statement actually around
this idea of um in feebleman and that
ultimately the worst thing that might
happen here is that we just become lazy
and that the machines originally
replaced our physical labor and so we
ended up doing more mind-based work and
that's fine because we end up actually
growing a society and growing the
economy as a result but that if even
that kind of work is now under threat
what if what are we left with
economically speaking um what but this
is this is the key thing so they use the
word enfieldman and that has a framing
you know it's a little bit like there's
a discussion about Universal basic
income and a lot of people with a
certain political persuasion assume that
it will make people lazy they'll just
sit and watch Jeremy Kyle all day
they'll just watch Trash TV they'll just
drink alcohol and do nothing and I know
that I wouldn't do that I know that I
would be taking every single minute of
the day to like learn and do cool things
and you know this is like a fundamental
framing on your kind of faith in
humanity I think we might start to see
this play out in the real world and
we'll start to get a flavor of what the
actual impact is in schools and I think
this is the first place where I would be
looking as a researcher into whether
this sort of stuff will come true as a
society as a whole is in the education
sector because yeah you know children
are now in a position where they can
have their essays written for them
they're in a position where any artwork
that they're doing can be at least in
part sort of inspired by Ai and even
produced by AI in many cases so if we're
talking about in feeblement the first
place I would be looking isn't in the
working Arena but it's in in the
classroom and if we can understand how
this technology is being used by
children and adopted by children I think
that will start to play out in the real
world when these children actually go
out and get jobs as well and um so if we
get this right
I think this is I'm I'm such a big
advocate for really
talking about this from a kind of
educational perspective first and
foremost and there's not enough I think
being done in terms of guidance from
from the government for example
um to actually understand how this stuff
is going to play out in the classroom
first because I think we'll take a lot
of learnings from that and see how
different kinds of students react for
example like yes a student like yourself
would just see this as a massive
opportunity to learn far more than they
could do ever before the technology
existed other students might see it as a
way to completely uh
um push any responsibility to the AI and
just go home and play Playstation other
students might not use it at all and
they might not even and I think all of
these things will play out in the world
of work as well I think this is exactly
what's going to happen but we'll see it
first in the classrooms because
ultimately these are the children that
are going to be doing the jobs in the
future so we might as well see how they
start using the technology yeah but it's
a great example of the politics you know
how politicized this is because even in
the political Arena we don't know yeah
so people on the left think that
enfieldment is caused by the
psychosocial environment and like of
privilege and and wealth and so on and
people on the right think that you know
what creates striving is Market forces
and pressure and competition and stuff
like that and they they and you know
like it's difficult to describe me like
you know a lot of evidence suggests that
that might be a big component of it the
truth is usually in the middle yeah and
we don't know right so yeah okay
interesting
have this future where all sorts of
stuff is happening but it's no longer
our future we have been disempowered
giving away control to machines that
don't even need us for anything that's a
very bad situation let's not go there
not exactly empowered now
exactly yeah
thank you Max take Mark terrific opening
statement now we've got those results
quickly for you now on how many of you
said might change your minds I've been
told it's 92 percent of you
could vote a completely different way at
the end of uh this 90-minute debate so
let's see what happens and we'll keep
going in that Spirit
selection with your opening statement I
was going to say eight percent it's
quite High isn't it for somebody's not
even okay well
showing some of my tweets I wanted to uh
mention of that
okay so first of all we are still very
far from having human level AI the car
technology is very limited we have
systems that can
pass the bar exam but any 10 year old
kid can learn to clear up the dinner
table and fill up the dishwasher and
in minutes convincing them to do it is a
different story
any 17 year old can learn to drive a car
in about 20 hours of training we still
don't have domestic robots we still
don't have self-driving cars at least
level five startup in cars so we still
have some basic uh you know major things
to progress to to to make to reach
machines that can reach human level AI
we're missing something big
there are immediate risks to AI but
those risks are not new there are things
like is AI going to be able to
generate a lot of misinformation or
convince people to do bad things or give
information to people that they
shouldn't have we already have the
internet we already have social networks
we already have counter measures against
things like disinformation and his
speech and things like that and by the
way all of those countermeasures make
massive years of AI
AI for those problems is the solution
it's not the problem
um
so now
is there
a basic design for AI that will make it
safe steerable
now if we extrapolate the capability
systems
I would agree that we might be worried
about the fact that
they may do bad things and be
non-controllable so if every most of you
probably have played with
autographs
Etc and you know that they confaborate
things they they make up facts that
don't exist they can't really reason
they don't plan they don't really
understand the reality of the world
because they're all purely trained on
text and most of human knowledge has
nothing to do with text
or with language for that matter so if
you believe that future AI systems are
based on the same
blueprint
I think you're entitled to beliefs that
it might be dangerous
and my prediction is that within five
years we're not going to be using those
things anymore next slide please
so what I'm proposing is something
called objective driven AI so this is a
type of AI whose behavior is controlled
by a set of objectives so those AI
systems cannot produce an output unless
it satisfies a number of constraints
safety constraints for example and
objectives that measure whether the
system sort of answers the question
they're being asked or satisfied
accomplish the tasks they want to do
those systems are controllable they can
be made safe as long as we implement the
the safe object the safety objectives
and the surprising thing is that they
will have emotions they will have
empathy they will have all the things
that we so I feel I've just got to stop
that
um I think that's pretty weak from
Lagoon
um satisfying the safety objectives I
mean that the whole thrust of what
tegmark is saying is that you have these
um instrumental goals and you have this
whole alignment it's like he's
trivializing the entire premise of the
alignment movement in about five
sentences so I mean even though I I'm a
fan of Lagoon I think that's a bit weak
I totally agree and this is exactly my
point that as soon as you've moved the
conversation to a broad brush debate
about whether there is a potential of an
existential risk you you're fighting on
the enemy territory if you like because
you know to just simply sort of say well
we're going to be able to build AI in
future that isn't the auto aggressive
models and you've got a point if if we
if we just stick with auto aggressive
stuff then which is effectively what he
just said is I don't think the point
that he was trying to make at all um
he's obviously got his own sort of views
about how we build Ai and future and
that he doesn't think things like GPT
are going to be how we're building AI
systems and even AGI in future you know
objective driven AI is the phrase that
he used but again I don't I wouldn't say
this sort of aligns to my own opinion
um and that he's he's sort of moving the
debate to territory that I think is very
easy for the the pro side to just knock
down and say you know well and in fact
Tech Mark um and benjia do say later you
know not everyone's like you Yan someone
is going to be out there building llm
based stuff and if that's what you're
afraid of then you know it's not
necessarily just going to be jeppa that
people are using in future so yeah I
mean I agree with it like yourself I
agree with the spirit of the the
argument but I think
you've got to flash your arguments out a
little bit more I think if you want to
really prove that point yeah and then
just so people know where we're joking
about jeopard but jepper is um Jan
lacun's joint embedded prediction
architecture and there's a hierarchical
version of it and it's based he uses the
pictorial formalism of energy-based
models which is why on every single
yamlukun talk you ever see you get these
beautiful little flowchart diagrams
which are based on his energy based
models and um
um I don't mean to be disparaging you it
was a cool paper but you know I think
it's um
we're kind of stabbing in the dark a
little bit when we talk about AGI
architectures at the moment so as soon
as you move the conversation to oh well
yeah what we've got at the moment is
scary but we're not going to do that in
future we just won't build bad stuff
like come on there's more there's
stronger arguments to the con side than
that I think um yeah and like yourself I
don't doubt that his his work is is
groundbreaking and phenomenal and I
think it probably will have a major
impact in future but that yeah you can't
just you know base the whole of human
society on your your papers and the
quality of them you know there's got to
be a more fundamental reason for for
your your arguments yep
we require
entities in the world to have if we want
them to behave properly so I do not
believe that we can achieve any anything
close to human level intelligence
without endowing AI systems with this
kind of
um
emotions
um similar to human emotions this will
be the way to control them now
I mean that's a bit weird as well so
there was this meme he went on Lex
Friedman and he said
um I take this glass and I push it off
the table when it falls off the table
and language models will never
understand this because they're just
trained on you know they're parasitic on
text and then you you ask gbt4 what
would happen if you pushed a glass off
the table and it knows
but this is the this is the rub isn't it
like it's mimic crew it doesn't really
know and Lagoon is saying that you know
our sensory experience our empathy our
subjective experience is crucial to
understanding and that's exactly what
John Searle said he said our phenomenal
experience our high resolution
experience is what you need to really
understand and then it's a question of
well what's the difference between
really understanding and mimicking it so
well that it doesn't really like it's
almost a distinction without a
difference yeah exactly and he mentions
the word emotion there which is quite a
interesting angle to take this debate as
well where you start sort of saying well
the way we control these um AI systems
is emotively you know and that's that's
dangerous territory if you're in a
debate like this because you're going to
get taken down you know by saying well
we can't really control humans emotively
so what's the what's to say you're going
to be able to have a subservient a AI
that is um being controlled because you
tell it to like behave itself so yeah I
find it a very strange argument and
again the spirit of it is there the idea
that you know something has to be more
physically embodied within the the world
exactly like you mentioned there for us
to be able to create problems and also
the fact that he's he's alluding to the
fact that we are nowhere near being able
to understand true intelligence in I
mean he he mentions there you know
things like
um laying the table or putting the
dishwasher on
um I think a a better way of framing
that is something like Arc where it's a
little bit more away from just robotics
um because I think you know you could
argue well the reason we can't do those
things is because perhaps the robotics
isn't strong enough it's nothing to do
with intelligence but I think Arc is
different because it is just about pure
intelligence so you're fighting on on
the right ground there to prove your
point
um rather than just sort of saying oh
you know it's we can't make it to make a
cup of tea and then the obvious counter
argument is well you know making a cup
of tea isn't necessarily important if
you're looking to kind of take down the
world but I think um to be able to argue
on the front of there are forms of
intelligence that we don't know how to
to embody to embed within a system and
and therefore we are always going to
have the upper hand that's a stronger
argument right because you can say well
we are okay more capable and you can't
just claim super intelligence if you
can't even solve Arc or the general
relativity thoughts experiment yeah and
there's a really interesting point there
you made about pure intelligence and
Melanie Mitchell of course um counseled
against this concept of pure
intelligence in her four fallacies paper
and then you you kind of bring in Chalet
and um it's it's actually interesting
because his measure of intelligence
paper arguably is describing a form of
pure intelligence but he cites Elizabeth
of spell key you know talking about this
core knowledge prize and and many of
those core knowledge priors are actually
kind of deducible from physical
macroscopic priors because you know
obviously it's the whole cognitive
psychology view on on AI so
um I I think Chalet actually would link
physical cognitive priors in in his
framework which would May arguably make
it not a pure intelligence and also
lacoon is is apparently contradicting
himself because he's talking about the
needs to have things like a motion to
understand but then on the other hand
he's he led by saying well we have
systems that can't do planning and and
reasoning and and kind of you know many
folks um who talk about pure
intelligence they index on the Primacy
of pure reason and and kind of almost
deliberately getting rid of all of the
emotional stuff so which one is it yeah
and and to extrapolate on that point
just a little further I think the thing
you mentioned there around Arc being is
kind of physical but also kind of not
you know it's not an actual physical
thing that it's manipulating absolutely
now's the point
um because there's the Spectrum from you
know large language models being able to
operate say within Minecraft where it
can tap into the physical laws of the
universe it can write python to actually
manipulate directly what happens there's
no
um there's no difference between writing
that python code and just tapping
directly into the Minecraft code base to
make something happen but I think Arc is
different because whilst it's still
digital it's still it's still an
environment that doesn't actually exist
you're presented it in a way that is
pixels and and colors are not objects
and that's important because the AI
system would need to understand the
concept of objects the concept of um of
obscurity if one object moves over
another without ever having to be
um without having ever had access to
those physical laws within the
environment and I think that's why for
me it makes it such an interesting
Challenge and why we're struggling with
it so much because it feels a lot closer
to the kind of intelligence that we seem
to have ourselves as humans
um and it's it's not in the same domain
as being able to play a game in
Minecraft be able to play the the
similar paper for example yeah um or the
the Cicero even within something like um
diplomacy the Cicero paper where they
they basically showed you could play the
game of Cicero using a large language
model you know these are all things
where you've got direct ability to
manipulate the environment absolutely
perfectly whereas Arc is all about you
know you don't have the ability to pick
that object up and put it over there is
that that language doesn't exist within
the arc
um problem set up it's just yeah pixels
it's about colors and it's about it's
about having some sort of zero shot
understanding that that is an object
well I'd never actually thought of that
yeah you're absolutely right so Arc is
an observational challenge so it's
non-interactive right basically and that
actually flies in the face of chalets I
mean he's big into embodiment and I
assume by extension
um and you know the inactive view of
cognitive science yeah it's purely
observational and very interesting and
also I just reflected on my previous
comments and I'm not sure that
um his system does require
um physical or physicality and the
reason for that is he's always talking
about abstractions and a lot of people
who talk about these cognitive priors
are talking their platonists basically
so they're talking about things that can
be abstracted outside of the physical
world that would exist even if the
universe didn't exist so things like
agentiveness or contains in or located
at these or like you know event
semantics these are things that don't
require physicality so
um that's a bit of an interesting I'd
love to know more about what Chalet
thinks about that yeah it seems like a
contradiction to be in the in the
platonic abstract world but also talking
about embodiment at the same time yeah
exactly and it it it's difficult to I
mean the more you think about this the
more you realize you don't understand it
but I think you know having read that
paper multiple times and actually
attempted a lot of the puzzles as well I
really feel that is the one example that
I can I can cite where I feel like
there's something magical going on in my
brain that I can't I cannot for the life
of me explain programmatically even with
my understanding of AI and and all of
the all of the examples that we're
seeing recently with GP T I can't I
can't find this this leap that that we
seem to be able to make ourselves and I
can't I can't seem to find ways of
describing that using existing
technology
um yeah and and to me the closest I can
get to explaining it is that I
physicality is a terrible word because
you know it's not a physical world that
we're dealing with with Arc but there is
something
intuitively that I I'm I'm representing
these objects not as pixels but as
object as as real things that I can move
in my mind without ever having seen that
exact example of a particular blob you
know it's it's very
um it's very difficult to sort of
put your finger on exactly why that is
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah in a sense because the the
psychology component is is all about how
humans think and I think that's the
missing link so they're saying the
reason why we can acquire these skills
so efficiently is because we are already
endowed with the cognitive prize and and
the reason we are endowed to the
cognitive prize is because we inherit
them from the physical world so we have
a kind of like
um a macroscopic physical conception of
what it means to be contained in so when
I think of contains in I'm thinking of
putting things in bottles or buckets and
so on and like you know we've got this
abstract category or concept which is
just a bag of analogies which we've
inherited from the physical world but
there's no reason in principle why a
computer you know would be able to
represent them in a purely abstract way
so there's a kind of interesting link
between like how how we acquire them and
how a computer works yeah I wonder if
it's possible to train like a
a a world model or even a large language
model that ends up having a world model
without any anything explicit being
programmed in just on Arc data and I
don't even know what that would begin to
look like but you know if you think
about gbt4 trained on text
um that it it manages to find ways to
um form capabilities and have theory of
mind to some degree without ever having
to be taught how to do that and through
text which is a medium that doesn't
really have that directly embedded into
it but what about if you could train
some sort of model in a similar regard
on the arc data so creating not Arc
puzzles programmatically but at least
Arc scenarios like you know stuff that
might happen in an arc-based world like
why some things are Arc puzzles and why
some things aren't Arc puzzles
um and and if there are a way to sort of
train models that could not solve Arc
puzzles but create Arc puzzles like
could you could you think about it the
other way around that you could build a
model to understand like
what what sort of stuff would I need to
see on a page for something to be
considered Arc worthy and what wouldn't
look like an arc puzzle to me because
then that that that moves the the
problem away from just an observation or
one of prediction prediction and being
able to symbolically manipulate objects
through to
um a little bit more like the GPT style
of like pre-training on just a body of
information and sort of encapsulating
within that model then an understanding
of how Stuff generally works and then
using that model to make predictive
inferences like gbt is being used to do
in a zero shot way yeah because I think
you're describing the inverse of Arc and
by the way we should just explain
arcchat that it stands for abstract
reasoning Corpus it's like a series of
about a thousand
um challenges that Francois chole
created so his big thing is all about
being able to generalize to tasks that
the developer of the system was not
aware of and there needs to be many of
them and they all um record you know
require knowledge of priors you know
like locate hated in agentiveness
directedness reflection repeating all
kinds of stuff like that and it's in a
2d grid world where you have these like
little colored cells and you get two or
three examples and you have to predict
what the next cell is so it's beautiful
because he's basically created the
perfect example to demonstrate you know
that language models cannot do that
um kind of like low information
extrapolation but but anyway you're
talking about the inverse problem which
is the ability to create new problems I
assume you meant given the priors and
the thing is that's the key thing if you
have the priors then it's easy right
sholay's big thing is about acquiring
the price if you have the prize you can
symbolically like you know create as
many new instances of problems as as you
as you want it's the ability to acquire
the prize efficiently that's the
challenge yeah so so the concept of
rotation for example would be a prior
exactly a concept of reflection yeah
exactly so I think um you know when you
ask yourself why why a particular Arc
problem exists you realize well first of
all it has to have exactly one solution
you know know it can't be if you just
had a random grid of pixels and it was
converted to another random grid of
pixels there's a myriad of ways of why
that might have been created that way
you know the change the thing in the top
right always gets changed to a blue the
thing and the thing next to the top
right gets changed to a yellow you know
and it becomes sort of it's so complex
to explain that that could never be
mapped across to any other problems and
it's about capturing you know why is
something an arc problem you know
beautifully
um encapsulated in that one puzzle and
you couldn't there's no way that you
could change it change a few pixels of
that and it'd still be true you know
it's those kind of ideas of robustness
to the yeah to The Domain and yeah we
talk about this all day really but I
think it gets to the heart of what we
mean by intelligence and I think large
language modeling is is in some way
showing us this ability to kind of
pre-train a knot for any particular one
task but just to understand the priors
and understand what generally exists in
a world and then to to use that model to
do things that are predictive and are
out of out of sample if you like yeah um
yeah so yeah I mean yeah I I mean I've
seen methods for kind of tackling Arc
which try to convert the puzzle into
natural language use gpt4 to then come
up with a solution in natural language
and then back to the original domain but
that seems like a long-winded way to go
round when maybe there's an argument for
saying well can we not just go direct
and build the world model and language
model itself it wouldn't be a language
model obviously but it would be a
foundational model I guess you might
describe it as but within the universe
of Arc but then of course you you know
you don't want to just sort of build a
huge training set where you're training
it on infinite data of Arc because that
doesn't exist the whole point is it's
hard to create them
um you know even to come up with a
thousand examples is arduous yeah
exactly and I mean Lacuna said that you
know text doesn't contain physical like
they call it naive physics you know like
kind of a world model of of how the
physical reality operates he might be
wrong on that so there might be a
mapping with all of those priors you
know like reflection and language
concept I mean they're almost certain
years so you could argue that all the
prize exists but we still have the
abduction problem and in my opinion
actually when I say abduction I kind of
I think it's analogous to what Chalet
means in terms of I've I've got this
like
um empirical data I've only got a couple
of examples and what I need to do is
select a set of cognitive priors right
and which ones do I choose and which
ones do I leave out that's abduction and
in a language model like yeah you could
argue that the prize or well first of
all there's there's the macroscopic
abstract priors and then there's the
prize and the actual model and the prize
and the model are hard-coded so they
can't be dynamically reselected and then
you still have the abduction problem in
in the language model and it doesn't
work yeah so yeah that's intelligence
yeah exactly I mean it's amazing to
think when we were blessed with this
this world that seems to create data for
us without us having to sort of create
those manual examples and like you're
right things like rotation reflection
they're all seemingly baked into laws of
physics in a very you know deep a
meaningful way in their symmetries of
other
conservations and things within the
universe so you know the fact that we've
discovered them and have have embedded
those within our language is
serendipitous that we can say well we've
got this large Corpus of data that we're
now training a world model on to to or a
foundational model that ends up being a
world model
um with Arc we don't have the
um the arc God I mean Chalet is as close
as we're going to get to it but there's
not something that's going to be able to
produce a sin of infinite many examples
of what Arc looks like so that we can
then create some sort of medium such as
language to describe what's going on in
the world train the foundation model and
map it back but yeah whether we can do
that from scratch but that is what we do
as humans isn't it when we're born we
don't have that world model of physics
and we are giving limited data to pretty
quickly pick up
um what the hell is going on well even
that's a point of contention yeah so
nativists say that we do yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah but then but then
the embodiment comes in as well because
actually we are physically perfectly
attuned to the environment we live in
and even even if we do it acquire these
Concepts empirically like clearly like
our natural
um compatibility like there's an
interface between our physicality in the
world we live in that's a kind of like
um physical prior yeah that allows us to
acquire those those physical Concepts
yeah the fact that we can learn how to
move and that in itself I mean it comes
back I mean you start breaching into
things like friston where it's about why
what makes me a self-defined entity over
things that are outside my Markov
blankets and all of this sort of stuff
and just so happens that we're perfectly
designed in such a way that we can take
actions to inform our perception and our
perception informs our actions and yeah
yeah so
um very very you can get deep very very
quickly on these things we're only we're
only two uh start talking less but just
final point this is like a a great
thought experiment which is that if you
wanted you know let's say you're in a
like RL gym moment or whatever it's
called and you had one blob of of
molecules and you were solving an
optimization problem to make the blob
like you know like walk and do lots of
things that we did climb ladders and so
on so you could optimize The Blob of
molecules from nothing or you could just
stick a kinematic model of a human in
there who's you know already got Limbs
and joints and stuff like that and and
all you're doing is you're just like
optimizing on the kinematic movement
like what's the easier problem yeah
exactly
um and also like which one
have you really solved anything with the
second example of that or are you just
sort of proving that you you can find a
set of parameters that you always knew
was going to exist
um in some sort of multi-dimensional
parameter space whereas in the first
example I guess there's less certainty
that something is even possible so yeah
um yeah I mean
yeah as soon as you start taking this
back to sort of absolute fundamentals
you you realize there's a ton of deep
deep problems that we have absolutely no
idea about and whilst large language
models are certainly very very capable
I agree with Ganda can in the sense that
you know we're missing big parts of this
puzzle still 100
one set of emotions that we can uh
hardwire into them is subservient the
fact that
they'll be auto service so imagine a
future it's pretty weak again isn't it
10 20 years from now perhaps
every one of us will be interacting with
the digital world through an AI
assistant they say assistant would be
our best digital friend if you want it
will
help us you know daily lives this will
be like having a staff of people who
might be smarter than us
and that's great
um have you working with a bunch of
people who are smarter than you is the
best thing you can ever do
um
oh why what did he say so if that's the
I can't remember the exact thing but he
said um something along the lines of
we've never been in a situation where
um we have got something subservient to
us which is smarter than us or something
like that and then Lagoon said well
that's rubbish like all of the engineers
that work for me are smarter than me and
like gave loads of examples of
situations where people are smarter than
the person they work for yeah yeah
exactly yeah
the case we would want those AI systems
to be transparent and open
kind of like Wikipedia if you want
We Trust Wikipedia because
the content is contributed by millions
of people who have been vetted and there
is some editing process and so we have
some level of trust in the veracity of
the content it's going to have to be the
same for AI system
the way they learn about the world
because they're going to be the
repository of all human knowledge will
have to be crowdsourced
which means they have they're going to
have to be open source
and if we are afraid that they are
a danger to humanity they cannot be open
source
so we're on the fork in the road are we
gonna go
keep this interlocking key as if it was
a weapon or are we going to go open it's
a good point and I really argue for
going uh open because I think AI is
going to open sort of a new era from for
Humanity the New Renaissance the new era
of Enlightenment if you want everybody
will be smarter for it and being smart
is intrinsically good
and I think there is a very uh
efficient way or good way of making AI
system safe is going to be arduous
engineering just like making turbojet
safe it took decades
and it's it's hard engineering but it's
doable
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I mean Tech Mark already
hedged against that because he said
there was a categorical difference
between jet engines and intelligence
yeah well exactly yeah I presume these
are all pre-prepared these speeches but
you've got to adapt to stuff like that
on the Fly I think yeah yeah
um again Lagoon two terrific opening
statements let's go for another and let
me just I don't think that was
particularly good from Lagoon no yeah I
mean exactly I feel like there's a lot
stronger arguments I think we'll hear
from Mitchell a few sort of real key so
hammer blows I think for the argument
which is yeah ultimately where we need
to get to okay yeah and and by the way
um if if is Melanie coming on next no
it's Benjamin yeah I just want to
express my love for Melanie but I'll
wait until she comes through Joshua
bengio you're up six minutes on the
clock
thank you
um let me start by stating something
that's probably obvious for many
researchers in Ai and Neuroscience but
for many people it isn't which is that
your brain is a machine it's a
biological machine that's what
neuroscientists trying to figure out
and what it means is that there's no
scientific reason to think that we
couldn't build machines as smart as
humans in the future
well
the world is a machine of which we are a
component of yeah so again he's kind of
gently going towards this
computationalist idea that there's a
pure intelligence your brain can exist
in a vat and it can exist in a computer
divorced of the world that we live in so
he's he's making a little nudge in that
direction from the beginning and and
also the fact I mean that that is not a
new argument I think anyone who's
studied the history of computing
um would would sort of realize that that
argument has been made ever since the
first computers were built and that we
are building a machine that's going to
be very very soon capable of being the
same as our brain yeah um so yeah it's
not enough to Simply say it's an
existential risk because it might be
able to be the case that we can build
something that's as far as the brain I
think the point is like how and also
we're missing big parts of this exactly
and I should also just make clear that
there are many very credible people out
there who vehemently disagree with the
idea of computationalism yeah I mean I
spoke with a um Theologian yesterday I
mean they think that we have souls
um idealists think that you know the
material world doesn't even exist John
so is a great example of of a property
dualist who he thinks that computation
is so you know there are lots and lots
of very very
credible academics who vehemently
disagree of this idea well when exactly
is another question but
um as Jeff Hinton has explained in a
recent talk
digital computers have advantages over
analog brains analog brains also have
advantages in terms of computer uh
Energy Efficiency but in terms of the
ability to absorb large quantities of
data and to share information at high
rates between computers so that they can
learn in parallel as Max was talking
about so you can have thousands of
computers sharing what they've learned
for example
um you know right now we already have ai
systems that can read the whole internet
very quickly which a human couldn't do
in in you know many ten thousands of
lifetimes
so so this gives them advantages if we
are able to build machines that have the
same principles of intelligence as we
have
um and that means it's very likely that
we'll build machines that are superhuman
now when is that going to happen
well
um
uh Jeff Hinton and Jan looker and and
myself who won the drink one for deep
learning actually all agree that it may
be anywhere between just a few years and
a few decades something like 5 to 20
years with some you know confidence
interval
now if it's a few decades that that you
know may be reassuring but as if a few
years I think we should be concerned and
in any case it doesn't change the
question of tonight which is is there
existential risk it's not about how far
into the future it is I changed my mind
about this whole question because the
time scale changed if you had asked me
just a few years ago I would have said
well maybe a few decades or centuries
because I thought like John uh like
Melanie that it was too far away
now the I'm sure many of you have tried
Chad GPT or GPT that was a contradiction
so he said the most important thing is
whether or not there is an existential
threat not how far away it was and then
he just said not five seconds ago that
previously I didn't care because I
thought it was far away yeah exactly I
mean it always annoys me a little bit
when
there's no time limit on this kind of
debate because you could kind of EX you
could explain to anyone well there's
going to be a risk of anything in the
future and that we need to at least put
some sort of bounds on the debate so we
can say like within this time frame we
think that something is going to happen
because otherwise you yeah you just
extrapolate to the point of view where
you know you could say well of course
it's going to be an existential risk in
the future like at some point when all
of these technologies that we haven't
invented yet come into existence and I
just find that amazingly weak yeah
exactly and if it is a binary it's
exactly analogous to this Bostrom
argument that there's an existential
risk to Future simulated lives on Mars
of which he thinks there'll be billions
or even trillions therefore
um you know people starving in Africa
right now don't matter so this this
extreme extrapolation and the problem
with this form of consequentialism as
well is that it's predictive right not
not only are you kind of like um
expanding the cone of space but you're
expanding the cone of time and you're
talking about things which have not
happened might not happen it's pure
speculation with no plausible credible
mechanism correct yeah the mechanism is
everything for me that's where I started
to really listen and as soon as until
that point it's just you know things
might happen in the future that are bad
and yeah of course yeah so let's talk
about what they might be and until that
point we're in no man's land the other
thing I just briefly mentioned on that
is um you know he mentions at scale and
we hear this argument quite often which
is that if we can build one superhuman
AI well imagine what a thousand could do
or you know to extrapolate again but
again my argument would be it only took
one human to come up with general
relativity it would it doesn't
necessarily need to be at scale in order
to be powerful but also I would say
scale doesn't equate to wisdom just
because you can do something faster or
bigger or better or more
there is often a leap that you need to
make that you can't just do by doing
more of it and I think we see that that
we see that with previous scientific
discoveries as I mentioned before
where it just took one person an
incredible leap of intelligence and
that's something that no other human
could have helped with or if if they'd
have had teams of thousands of
scientists all working on this they
would have all probably come to the same
conclusion which is that Einstein was
wrong and in fact that is what happened
so yeah it's whether like scale equates
to wisdom and I wouldn't say it does it
was a really interesting point there
which is that um scientific progress is
a bit like Tetris that some you know if
you get a block in the right place
sometimes you some you know you jump
down five blocks and then there's
there's an interesting kind of
relationship between scaling up and
scaling out and you could argue that
even with the level of intelligence we
have now if you had 10 000 John Von
Neumann's one of them were just happen
upon that Discovery and it's what
bostromium calls the urn experiment the
black earns so you're you're pulling
urns out of this pot and the rate of
intelligence
um means that you're going to be pulling
urns out faster and then you're going to
hit a black urn so it's not necessarily
about the the um the capability of the
individuals it's about the rate of
applying it intelligence yeah that's
fair so I see what you're saying so it's
effectively saying well even if we had
you know a certain number of sub uh
Einstein level people with a certain
amount of Randomness perhaps we would
just happen upon something that then
that you know everyone else could kind
of all of the other systems could
collate around but still I think that
there's a there's a huge amount of
missing elements to that
um that argument and I think generally
speaking that there's no way that we're
going to be able to just simply pour
more compute and more Super
intelligences into this this thing they
would all have to certainly have their
own experiences perhaps be trained on
different data sets yeah and for that to
be a valid argument that more is better
if we've just got more of the same thing
doing you know trained on the same data
I would argue that you wouldn't
ultimately just pour more um weight into
the prior and less into
um actual science and actual logical
thought and symbolic thought I guess to
be to be sort of marcusy about it
um the idea that you know this isn't
just about stochastically moving around
some sort of lacent space of ideas until
you stumble across something that that
might be true
um it's about actually taking an idea
and running with it logically and
there's a trajectory that you would have
to walk along from a logical perspective
that you couldn't stumble upon if you
just move stochastically along all
possible trajectories yeah
um you you start quickly coming into
sort of absurd numbers if you start
doing that and absurdly small
probabilities of happening upon the
right solution yeah if you just
just use something like gbt4 to sort of
walk along paths at random as as you
just mentioned there or not at random
but certainly you know with with the
limited amount of scientific knowledge
that a gbt4 trained on data up until a
certain point of time would have
um so yeah there's it's an interesting
argument and I mean that's something I
would love to sort of dive into deeper
perhaps with somebody from the opposite
side of the debate because I think that
gets to the heart of it doesn't it a lot
of the X risk side of the debate is is
arguing that scale is the thing that we
should be worried about but you know
it's not just one super intelligence but
it's the fact that it can it can do
things so much faster than us and I've
heard before you know the argument that
it's nine hours worth of
um its time is worth like a Year's worth
of human time or something along those
lines
um yeah but I mean on on that point I
wanted to just add another comment to
this idea that intelligence is
situational and a lot of um scientific
discovery is serendipitous and linked to
the physical situation you're in and and
also being in the right place at the
right time for example Benjo won the
touring award
um we don't really live in a meritocracy
right I'm not saying that Benjo isn't
brilliant he is but he was in the right
place at the right time you know like he
was just all of the the Stars aligned
for him he's now extremely powerful he
has 900 people working for him at Miller
and his successes basically a
self-fulfilling prophecy right and
that's that's the way it is with the 10
000 John Von neumans you know like with
Einstein yes he was very intelligent and
so on and he consistently made good
discoveries but he he probably was just
sat by a lake and just looking at a pond
at the right place at the right time and
he had that flash of inspiration and you
know
it a lot of it is just luck yeah that's
a nice way to put it um I think that's
true and we also need to separate out
are we are we scared of super
intelligence or are we super scared of
scale because I mean a lot of these
arguments about scale could also be
applied to
um the fact that we we could iterate
over lots and lots of different
combinations of you know
um of Bio weapons very quickly are we
are we really scared of for Loops or are
we scared of intelligence you know that
we need to we need to be clear about
what we're actually worried about here
is it that super intelligence is able to
do it better than we ever could from an
intelligence perspective or you know
recursion in general is something we
should be scared about with all systems
yeah for me it feels like the two often
get blurred um it's to the point where
the the X riskers end up arguing for
recursion over intelligence and
um
yeah I mean my argument would always be
if one of these things is enough right
if it's super intelligent then why do
you need lots of different super
intelligences in order to
to cause us an X risk very briefly as
well we come to it later in Melanie
Mitchell's um Exposition I think but she
says
um the idea that
um it's going to be intelligent enough
to cause a serious harm but also not
intelligent enough to realize that it's
running on our architecture and and
therefore causing us harm might be
something that it wouldn't want to do
um so this idea of a sort of a dumb
super intelligence where it's it's very
very very good at certain things but in
other things it's got the paper clip
problem and it doesn't understand that
that's a stupid thing to do so why why
are we you know why would it be super
intelligent in one respect and not
another
um but yeah we can we'll come to that I
think in the future cool parts of the
debate
four and
uh you you can't uh really like avoid uh
not as saying that these machines are
incredibly uh powerful in fact they pass
what Turing who gave his name to the
price we won
um uh defined as the train test in the
sense that when you imagine quite a lot
through the oh did he win the touring
award yeah yeah oh just in case you
missed it at home folks he won the
touring award uh dialogue with these
systems uh you may not be sure if you're
talking to a human or a machine
now it's been also uh the job of many
scientists like myself to try to figure
out what is missing and I agree with Jan
and Melanie that there are important
ingredients missing but
are they something we'll figure out in
just a few years or a few decades it's
hard to say I can tell you that the
things that I'm working on uh which is
something on the order of uh reasoning
um right now G flow Nets G flow Nets
yeah g flow net which are very cool yeah
very cool we um we did a show with Benjo
on g-flow Nets oh yeah yeah very cool
stuff
um yeah now these these systems they're
really good at something like intuitive
intelligence but not so much at
reasoning and and thinking through
before they're saying stupid things
um is something that could potentially
be solved very quickly or maybe there
will be obstacles on the way we don't
know
so so this is a this is a problem and as
as Max said once uh the the recipe for
building these things is available or
even worse the the parameters the weight
so somebody could download this and and
give it instructions that could be very
very harmful because imagine systems
that are many times smarter than us
could defeat our cyber security
um could hire you know organized crime
to do things could even hire people who
are legally working on the web to do
things could open bank accounts
um could do all kinds of things uh just
through the internet and and eventually
do the r d to build robots and and have
its own like controlled Direct Control
in the world
many times smarter than us I mean I just
disagree with that on principle again
intelligence is situational and how can
someone like Benjo who understands the
concept of the curse of dimensionality
right so you know like the the euclidean
space the volume of the space increases
exponentially with Dimensions it's the
same with intelligence right so you can
have pointillistic chess programs that
are very good at chess like having an
intelligence which is smarter than us in
many domains requires an exponential
increase in the traversal of states that
you need to discover like it's
completely obvious to me why is it not
obvious to him yeah I think we should
ban the word smart from these debates as
well I can't stand the word smart I
think it's completely vague I don't know
what it means uh in the context of what
he's talking about you know smartness is
a
it could mean so many things like are we
talking about savviness or are we
talking about knowledge intelligence
reasoning like let's be really precise
with these kind of words when we're
using them I think first and foremost
um but yeah I think as well you know to
say something like we're we're going to
have machines that are smarter than us
so again like
does he mean solving Arc does he mean
making Cups of Tea does he mean doing
the dishes like um the Kun points out or
does he mean you know searching over a
huge uh space of
um potential you know bio weapons and
and narrowing down it's just too vague
the whole the whole thing for me I can't
I can't focus on the argument unless
there's a specific mechanism being
talked about and yeah I think I I just
think it's it's not helpful to kind of
just say things like we're going to have
machines that are smarter than us we
already have machines that are smarter
than us in so many ways in narrow
domains so why does you know why does it
necessarily matter if we have one
machine that is generally capable rather
than many machines that can do specific
tasks very well as we have now yeah you
know what he needs to make the argument
that a generalist machine is more
dangerous and if so I'm willing to
listen to that argument but it's not
good enough to say we're going to have
machines that are smarter than us in
future because it's already here yeah
and and I want to touch on that point
again that you know benjio
um it's not meritocracy he's got 900
people working for him so that the
skills that
um that he's employing now to execute
power or to you know prosecute power
um has little to do with his
um intellect in respect of machine
learning right he's using a completely
different set of skills his uh his
communication skills his PR skills and
and so on and there was an interesting
point as well about look at intelligence
of humans right the world is not run by
Mensa right there's no relationship
whatsoever I mean if anything there's an
inverse relationship the more
intelligent you are the less power you
have so why why is it a foregone
conclusion that having more intelligence
leads to Prosecuting more power and I
can't see any rationale for that yeah
for sure
so in a way where are we going is
and that's really uh I'm challenging
Jeff Hinton here uh you know coming up
with a new kind of entity in the world
that may have its own
um self-preservation goals which is
something that also Max explain
self-preservation as well why is it a
foregone conclusion that an intelligence
system would want to preserve itself
it's a it's a common another Trope I
think that we hear a lot from the X-ray
side is this idea of self-preservation
um and again it's detail matters like we
need to start talking about what that
physically looks like do we have the
systems all ready to do this if so what
do they look like if not what do we need
to discover before they become relevant
just to kind of throw ideas like we're
going to have machines that self
preserve I I mean I just you didn't even
know where to start to kind of argue
against it because it's there's nothing
specific you can tangibly grab hold of
yeah and and this all comes back to this
notion of an instrumental goal which is
that if you tell the agent to do
something
um
they they say well obviously an
instrumental goal will be
self-preservation because if you pull
the plug it won't be able to achieve its
goals well why is that obviously that's
the question is it is it obvious and
that again where's the mechanism so they
say oh look it appears as if language
models have instrumental goals so you
know we train them on this kind of like
microscopic perplexity thing and then
they appear to have these instrumental
goals but the problem is the goals even
a theory of mind the goals are
anthropocentric projections they're
lenses that we use to understand their
behavior like we don't actually know
that they have these instrumental goals
no precisely
um yeah it does it comes back to you you
know we've trained this on human data so
it's it's not a surprise that the human
uh
human ideas and human um things that we
anthropo authorized come through in the
data so something like self-preservation
I'm sure you could get gpt4 to quite
happily start talking about how it wants
to live forever and that it's quite
happy but that's not that's not it's
it's will that's just it's learned from
Human data that's what humans generally
say so there's a big leap I think and
it's often it's easy to confuse the two
between you know is it just saying what
it believes the next word would be in
the sentence and quite often we talk
about wanting to to live or is it
actually coming up with its own
objective to to maintain itself
um because you know in the former case
I'm pretty sure you could with a few
prompts tell it to say exactly the
opposite thing um so yeah it's very
brittle I think and part of what makes
us amazing as humans is our ability to
hold multiple ideas in our head
simultaneously and not necessarily
um not necessarily kind of
attach any of those to our language
model the thought seems to exist
separately from our what we what we say
you know and
I think with like with language models I
think what you often see is that the the
the the the context window itself
contains what it believes or what it has
been told to believe and that I mean I
would be really interested to sort of
see systems where
um
it can hold an idea in its memory and
yet
unpromptedly about something completely
um counter to what's in its own store if
you like its own memory store yeah
without you know a human saying could
you say something that you don't believe
you know I wanted to you know how would
it how would it even do that how would
it even be able to hold alternative
ideas within its own
um its own output of you know the
language model
without it being explicitly told to do
that thing as a weekend I can say
something to you that I don't believe
right now without you saying to me
um would you mind just saying something
you don't believe you know it's yeah
exactly yeah where's that inner voice
coming from and that's the abduction
again because I can say to a language
model pigs fly yep like you know answer
questions on the basis that pigs fly and
and fundamentally they are information
retrieval systems right they're not
they're not intelligent systems and as
you say they just take everything on
face value exactly if if they didn't
then maybe they would be intelligent
yeah and I also want to like just
quickly touch on this thing that we said
earlier which is that you know they they
said reflexivity recursivity you know
it's it's suddenly going to create this
huge danger and well based on what we
know about Auto GPT that's convinced me
that there is no danger right because
they don't have this exact ability that
you just spoke off right they they don't
have this Dynamic reflection this like
post-rationalization there's system two
or call it what you want they they just
their information retrieval systems yeah
really interesting yeah point I mean
also GPT I think is the one of the
largest growing fastest growing open
source repos of all time I think it's
gotten the verge of about 150 000 stars
now and on GitHub and yet I haven't
really seen it do anything beyond no
order a pizza or Garbage
um so that's a lot of people looking at
this building impressive supposedly
impressive things without it actually
materializing and you know it's not to
say I'm not you know one of these people
who says well because it's not been done
yet it won't be done of course like
these systems might evolve and adapt to
to do impressive things in future but
again it feels like something's missing
like something is fundamentally missing
that allows it not just to break a task
down into priorities and then sub
priorities and enact those in some sort
of logical tree-based way but to be able
to say to itself
can I can I hold some sort of
alternative idea in my head without it
having to
um be told explicitly to do that or even
to be told to that it might be a thing
that it wants to consider to do you know
it's yeah there seems to be something
missing basically and I can't put my
finger on what but it's it's interesting
to discuss I know and it's it's very
similar to when Connor said to me oh Tim
it is reasoning you just can't see it
and and admittedly in a way I was wrong
because it was and I couldn't see it and
now we see it is and they're using the
same argument
um it is doing all that stuff that you
just said it has intentionality it has
it has like goals it has beliefs it can
deceive us it is doing it you just can't
see it so they're basically saying we
can see the media coming towards the
Earth and you can't it's it comes down
to that yeah and this is why it's
important for our side of the argument
to come up with concrete mechanisms that
we think aren't currently possible so
we've talked today about you know Arkham
we've talked about different thought
experiments that we might do that could
actually be done in the real world to
kind of show the limits of what's
possible there's a lot being talked
about I think especially in the Sparks
of AGI paper about what it is capable of
doing and all of the amazing things that
it might be able to do in future but um
there's also equivalent you know papers
and on the opposite side which are
trying to show that it's there's deep
limitations to this technology I can't
remember that I read one the other day
that um
compositionality yeah yeah exactly
there's things like that where
you know they're trying to show look
hang on a minute like what are we really
what have we really built here is this
something that's going to extractively
move us to a new sort of way of thinking
about intelligence or actually is it
just a very very useful system that will
certainly do a ton of useful things in
the world but ultimately has hard
ceiling limits you know yeah yeah
bad or it may happen because of what I
call a Frankenstein sort of uh tendency
of us wanting to build machines that are
like us and and once we have machines
that have a self-preservation goal well
we are in trouble
um you know think about what happens
when you want to survive you don't want
uh others to turn you off right and you
need to be able to control your
environment which means control humans
so
um existential risk isn't just well we
all disappear it might be that we're all
um disempowered that we are not anymore
in the control of our destiny and and I
don't think this is something we want
um last slide which I won't have time to
go in details but yeah we're not in
control of our destination
I'll post soon where I've tried to take
all of the comments and questions that
people have asked me
um uh about this question uh and and
trying to answer all the uh the critics
about oh we should not worry about
existential risk
um and up to now I unfortunately I
haven't been convinced by these these uh
arguments I would really like to be
convinced uh and and lay these these
concerns to rest
um but uh all of the arguments I've
heard and we'll discuss tonight uh have
not been good enough
oh they were just clapping to make them
shut up
let's have Melanie Mitchell give our
final opening statements six minutes on
the clock Melanie yeah so this is this
is my opportunity to say I love Melanie
she is amazing and and she's coming back
on mlst
in about two weeks oh amazing yes it
gives a good representation of herself
in in here I think Melanie is amazing
out machines on unleashing human
extinction have deep roots in our
Collective psyche these fears are as old
as the invention of machines themselves
but tonight we're debating whether these
fears belong in the realm of Science
Fiction and philosophical speculation or
whether AI is an actual real life
existential threat
I'm going to argue that AI does not pose
such a threat in any reasonably near
future
first I'll argue that the possible
scenarios that people have dreamed up
for AI existential threats are all based
on unfounded speculations rather than on
science or empirical evidence
second while we can all acknowledge that
AI presents many risks and harms none of
them rise to the extreme level of
existential saying that AI literally
threatens human extinction sets a very
high bar
finally
claiming that AI is an existential
threat is Excel harmful it misleads
people about the current state and
likely future of AI
such sensationalist claims
deflect attention from real immediate
risks
and further might result in blocking the
potential benefits that we could reap
from technological progress
let's look at the three scenarios that
people have posited for AI to be an
existential risk
is that a malevolent super intelligent
AI somehow emerges and uses its Evil
Genius to destroy Humanity we've all
seen that movie I believe that no one
here takes that scenario seriously
for the foreseeable future AI systems
will not have their own desires or
intentions for good or for evil the way
that living beings do they're not alive
the second scenario is also that a super
intelligent AI emerges but it's not
malevolent it just misinterprets our
wishes and accidentally kills us all
just quickly on that um it's not alive
now you could push back on that and
you know I spoke with this Theologian
yesterday and and he said that um oh you
know this this AI thing was ridiculous
it's not omnipotent it couldn't create
the universe and this is an interesting
angle it's not alive but what does it
mean to be alive does it mean by the way
the definition of life is one of the
most complex uh definitions imaginable
it doesn't exist
um and you can come at it from different
angles but so self-replication is an
example so you know it could be this
thing that exists in the info sphere and
even though it's kind of like parasitic
on the physical world it can replicate
itself around and you turn off that
computer well it doesn't matter because
it's on every other computer and it
becomes increasingly difficult to turn
off all of the computers at the same
time you know therefore for all intents
and purposes it's alive yeah and exactly
and it's sort of I think she made a
really great point but then by saying
it's it's not alive actually I don't
think it's relevant to the conversation
because you could foreseeably create
something that isn't alive and yet still
has desires and wants there's no reason
why those two have to be completely
exclusive from one another but the point
I think she's making is that those wants
and desires are coming from ultimately
humans like whether it's the initial
prompt of something that it's had to do
um or coming from it well its own kind
of Bank of information about things it
might want to do given that initial
prompt and sub-prompting and so on and
ultimately those still come from humans
because it's inhuman data
um so yeah I think the point that she's
trying to make is that it's a big leap
to sort of say well these large language
models are going to come up with their
own desires from the nothingness and
from without prompting about a
particular objective to then see them as
running away with their own sort of will
to go and destroy us
um yeah so it's a it's a a difficult
point to argue on I think in this debate
because on the one hand I can see that
the post side would simply say well we
don't even need to cover the case where
the AI has its own wants what about if
it's just all human generated and that
in itself is enough of a risk
um but it's certainly is certainly
relevant I think to mention in a debate
like this that just to say that AGI is
going to have its own wants and desires
is not something that we have the
ability to build at the moment for sure
yeah I'm a bit torn on on this one uh
because John soles talks about
intentionality and actually
um even Christians that they say that
it's um because it comes from our soul
and they say that the presence of
Consciousness in of itself implies that
we have a soul that's what this guy said
yesterday and the pro side would just
say or someone like Blake lemmeon would
say well for all intents and purposes
this thing does have intentionality it
does have Consciousness like you know I
confront the language model I can say to
the language model what do you want to
do in this situation and it will tell me
what it wants to do therefore it has
intentionality what's the meaningful
difference well I would argue the
meaningful differences is that the
quality of the intentionality right
because real physical agents embodied in
the real world they actually have
intentionality which has a certain
valence has a certain value right
um which is categorically different to
the value of what a language model would
would want yeah I'm a bit conflicted on
this thing yeah I I'm in the same boat
to be honest with you I mean I think
when I sort of start thinking about it
it's um it's the difference between
the fact that um a large language model
but also agent-based llms like Auto GPT
there still feels a very sort of
sequential
or even if it's parallelized way of sort
of processing information and thinking
about the world it doesn't it doesn't
ever
it doesn't ever do something
out of nothingness there's always a
cause to what it's doing and I I feel
I feel something about what we do is
it doesn't it seems to be the the
consequences is has come from something
that isn't necessarily because I've been
prompted to do something and it I'm
probably not explaining that very well
but it's a it's an idea that um I
suppose goes back to
Canon llm ultimately just spontaneously
decide to take a course of actions in
the same way that it feels like a any
sort of living being can spontaneously
decide to do something
um I mean I feel myself even talking
about it sort of I'm using extremely
loose language the kind of that I don't
particularly like when others do but
um yeah it comes back to this idea of
spontaneity whether an llm can be
released on a stream of inbound
information rather than just
prompt answer prompt answer prompt
answer in the way that it is at the
moment I feel like I think it's telling
that you know our brain doesn't seem to
we haven't noticed anything about it
that is particularly similar to a way an
llm works it's not as if we
we have modeled large language models on
the brain and and we can look at the
brain and say yeah there's the you know
the architecture that is is effectively
predicting the next word
um
so it feels like you know the way that
the brain works is very different to the
way that we've got llms to work and
therefore I mean I don't think it's very
Justified to sort of say well we can
therefore extrapolate from llms and say
we've got something here that is akin to
what we're doing
um
and yeah yeah so it's difficult to kind
of know exactly why that is but um yeah
yeah then there's them as well there's a
weird spectrum of human chauvinism here
as well and even Melanie has softened
her position she had that paper out
about different modes of understanding
and she's kind of accepting that there
could be different modes right of of
thinking you know intentionality
understanding and and so on
um yeah and this very good this is a
great example of how quickly discussions
in ai go to philosophy because exactly
um you know who's to say what creativity
is and we spoke with Dennis recently and
he's a compatibilist which means that
you know he thinks that it's not a
contradiction to you know live in a a
deterministic world and still have free
will and who's to say that like we're
not just stochastic random number
generators that's what the the pro side
say and it's a great example of if
you're a smart person arguing on either
side you can think of like you know good
good claims here yeah do you not feel
though there's a difference between the
way say Auto GPT is coming up with sub
goals and subpriorities to solve one
ultimate goal and then it would stop and
I can't honestly tell you what my
priorities and goals are at the moment
accepted a very very high level and the
multi most of the things I do in my life
are not actually working towards those
and I feel yeah I feel there's a huge
difference between What A system that is
we are literally talking here now about
is potentially leading to AGI
recursiveness Auto GPT self
um being able to give goals to itself
being able to reason and and and what we
are doing sitting here now
leading Our Lives seemingly in many ways
sort of goal-less and just existing and
taking actions based on what we see
around us yeah I mean again we start
we're going to philosophy now is there's
nothing where I can say I can point to
something and say this is exactly what
I'm doing and this is different from
what Auto GPT is doing I just feel it's
different well yeah no it is different
but the question is does it matter
and so property dualists and substance
dualism religious people they would say
that it couldn't
um it couldn't be creative and it
couldn't have intentionality in
principle and I'm not sure I agree with
that I'm making the argument that it
could do in principle the reason why
um the value of its creativity is not as
good as ours is because there's a
fundamental missing capability right
let's see yeah yeah so it's almost the
quality of the regardless of whether
what it's doing is the same as what
we're doing it's just not as as as
capable in the quality of its um it's
its reasoning but also its ability to to
hold counter factual ideas in its head
and hold those in just the same regard
for a fleeting moment only to dismiss it
instantly and move on to another all of
that sort of stuff is missing still
exactly so so Denny would say in
principle these systems can have
autonomy autonomy as a scale
intelligence is a great you know
everything's a gradual Continuum but
there's just a fundamental lacking
capability and I think based on what
Melanie said is she's arguing that I
think she would argue it couldn't happen
in Prince support
sort of like a Sorcerer's Apprentice
gone nuclear
for example yahshua benjio wrote about
this thought experiment we might ask an
AI to fix climate change and to solve
the problem it could design a virus that
decimates the human population
Presto humans dead no more carbon
emissions
this is an example of what's called the
fallacy of dumb super intelligence
that is it's a fallacy to think that a
machine could be quote smarter than
humans in all respects unquote and still
lack any Common Sense understanding of
humans such as understanding why we made
the request to fix climate change and
the fact that we'd prefer not to be
wiped out
intelligence is all about having insight
into one's goals and the likely effect
of one's actions beautiful we would
never give unchecked autonomy and
resources to an AI that lacked these
basic aspects of intelligence it just
does not make sense
the third scenario yeah that is
absolutely she made that point so much
more eloquently than I've tried to make
in in the past yeah even early in this
conversation I was trying to try to get
that across but that's exactly it it's
this dumb super intelligence you know
yeah exactly but also there's a
tangential point about morality itself
you know which is that
um you know whether moral facts can
exist and the extent to which it would
be aligned with our morality because
that's a link to to the why right you
know like there's there's a moral
component to the why and why wouldn't an
intelligence So Sophisticated understand
that and maybe they would argue well it
does understand it they just don't care
right because they are fundamentally
misaligned with us and they don't
necessarily care about the preservation
of humanity yeah yeah exactly I mean
it's a really critical part of the whole
debate I think is this idea of how super
intelligent you want your super
intelligence to be and and I think that
you on the express side we often sort of
hear about people picking and choosing
you know they're super intelligence is
good enough to um be able to come up
with the ultimate uh nuclear weapon that
you know was far more capable and
somehow gets created as a result of its
own intelligence never mind the fact
that it's not really able to build
anything in the physical world but never
mind but it's not um capable enough to
realize that it's running on Hardware
that's ultimately human generated and
therefore that weapon will destroy not
any Humanity but its own you know
Hardware so yeah I feel like the debate
slowly becomes more and more kind of um
uh about what kind of intelligence you
want to pick and choose for your
argument and which ones you want to
conveniently leave out yeah yeah
interesting yeah and it just made me
think that maybe you know what would
what would a stable beautiful Society
look like would it be this like
incredible Nash equilibrium where you're
on the border of chaos where you have
all of these like competing forces
counterbalancing each other
anyway interesting oh is that a
genocidal group of humans uses AI to
help them destroy Humanity indeed humans
often use technology to do very bad
things but we can't conclude from this
that AI research and development is
itself an existential threat a terrorist
group could conceivably carry out a
nuclear biological attack that kills
millions of people with or without AI
there's information online right now
about how to make weapons how much one
might go about killing millions of
humans AI systems could make it easier
to get that information but the threat
is still there without AI oh I love
Melody but more importantly our society
our institutions and our Technologies
are enormously complicated diverse and
resilient
they create a barrier of complexity that
puts the brakes on such an attack which
would require a Cascade of Highly
improbable events
everyone here would agree that there's a
long list of actual near-term risks and
harms of AI such as the spread of
disinformation or job losses
we should take those risks very
seriously
but it's also well only now this far
into the introductions has someone
mentioned present risks yeah wow how far
in are we a long way in that's that's
remarkable end of itself harmful to take
unfounded speculations about
unexistential threats too seriously
consider vaccines which provide immense
benefits in mitigating diseases
but we've seen calls for them to be
severely restricted and even halted due
to unfounded speculations about their
risks
we don't want to kill off potential
benefits from AI in science
in health care or education
would you call science itself an
existential risk
it gave us nuclear weapons after all but
not pursuing science is an even greater
existential risk
just as for vaccines and other
Technologies our assessments of AI
threats need to be founded in science
not and empirical data not unsupported
speculations there's no evidence that AI
research and development poses an
existential threat now or in the
reasonable future thank you
oh yeah beautiful it's a great evening
let's finish isn't it yeah I mean that
captured so many of the different ideas
that we've talked about I think and
um you know one of the main ones being
evidence I mean that's that's what
scientists act upon isn't it if they see
evidence contrary to what they currently
believe then they're going to of course
change their mind and what what the X
risks I'd need to come up with is this
mechanism or at least plausible future
mechanisms even if they don't currently
exist and of course we need to prepare
so it's not just about waiting until
it's possible and then saying oh we
really should be thinking about this but
at least we've got to have some sort of
some sort of understanding about what
exactly we're worried about otherwise
you know it quickly descends into
philosophy or it descends into a
conversation more about the you know the
potential for for something to happen at
a very broad level like recursive
um self-president self-preserving AGI so
yeah exactly that show me some evidence
that we've got something on our hands
here that is extraordinarily capable
beyond what we're currently able to
control yeah and and she was actually
making a bit of a and and implication
that this is anti-science you know which
is
further making the implication that this
is a form of religion yeah because
they're basically saying you need to be
really worried about it's a little bit
like you're going to go to hell you know
if you do something wrong it's like they
are they are threatening that we're all
gonna die and bad things are going to
happen and you need to trust me but I'm
not going to give you any credible
mechanistic explanation of why yeah and
it is to be clear as well I mean I don't
doubt that in future there is a small
chance that we might face something
where you know we turn around and go
yeah that's something now we need to
call existential risk and we're super
scared by it as much as anybody else but
again there will be that will be
foreshadowed by a period where we
understand that that sort of stuff will
be possible in future and that's
important I mean I would I would quite
happily sit here and in the future say
if I look back at the reviews
conversation I would still write to say
those things I said even though now I
can see we have mechanisms to do these
things in future but what I'm not going
to do today is sit here and say well I'm
going to be scared of all future
scenarios because of things that I can't
understand at the moment and I've got no
way of possibly appreciating how that
thing might you know reasonably come to
fruition
um because otherwise you would I I could
sit here and have the same conversation
about alien alien invasion and a good
thing I always think to do when you're
listening to any debate on ago or just
any debate to be honest existential risk
is if replace the subject with alien
invasion and see if the argument's still
still holds you know a lot of this idea
about
um you know we're gonna we're gonna be
faced with
um
self-preserving AGI in future
okay so now if you turn that into a
conversation about Alien Invasion that
we'll be invade invaded by a species
that wants to self-preserve and destroy
us the first question we would ask is
well have we seen stuff like this like
what's the evidence for this in the real
world have we have we got evidence of
signals coming in from species that seem
to reproduce that seem to want it
because then I'll take you seriously
yeah and again so the same thing is true
of AGI we need to show that this thing
even is possible to exist even if it
might not be not be actually gonna exist
in future but even has the possibility
to exist and through some sort of signal
or some sort of
um actual evidence and then we can have
the debate
um about what we do about it yeah and
then coming back to this kind of
paternalism and elitism Tech Mark kind
of hedged against that by saying oh the
real risk is the incremental
um acquisition of capabilities and this
is kind of what Conor was saying in the
way he said well what's the what's the
kind of like the least impressive
advancement that would make you change
your mind and that's a bit weird isn't
it because Connor says oh yeah well gbt4
isn't intelligent so it's almost like he
agrees with us that you know current
technology doesn't have the capability
so he's still in the speculative domain
but the core argument they're making is
that there's going to be such an
explosion in capability the blast radius
is going to be so big that it's going to
be faster than our ability to adapt to
it but they are still basically saying
we can see it it doesn't exist yet it
might happen therefore we need to drop
everything and stop progress yeah and
again it just comes down to you know
show me the evidence show me the
even even if it's not evidence in in the
sense of we've already got this thing
here with us but evidence that in future
there are ex there I can show you the
exact steps that we need to have in
place and I can show you the exact
pieces of the puzzle that we're missing
and that we are 70 75 of the way through
to at least having something that can do
this but I feel like a lot of the pieces
of the puzzle we are nowhere near
understanding and it's important I think
also to realize the difference between
this conversation today in this
conversation maybe 10 years ago is large
language models like foundational models
are the only piece of the puzzle that's
developed in terms of memory Stores
um prioritization planning we're still
using the same like cosine lookups as
you know the technology there hasn't
developed the ability to store
information
um and and forget stuff you know this is
all things that we're not talking about
as part of the AI Revolution yeah we are
simply talking about a A system that in
some small way seems to be able to
reason and plan to some extent and not
you you know not to the not to the
extrapolate events degree of of this but
just to some extent it seems to have
these emerging capabilities which is
really cool and very powerful for sure
but it's it's then another thing to say
well we're just going to bolt on
um some sort of vector lookup as its
memory store we're going to Bolt On
Tools like access to Wolfram Alpha or um
you know a python prompt and and this
kind of like
collection of sort of bits and Bobs will
somehow take over the world it's it's
all very um
we've built one thing that's quite
powerful and now we're sort of just
throwing and gluing on different sort of
bits to it and sort of saying that's AGI
yeah it's like really like that's all it
was it was just a large language model
with um Warframe Alpha connected and a
python prompt well I don't think so I
think the the brain there's something
elegantly beautiful about our own
understanding of of things in the brain
itself that um doesn't seem to look like
a collection of different sort of bolted
together yeah um bits and Bobs you know
and if it was then we would probably
have a much deeper understanding of
intelligence than we already do yeah
exactly and and Melanie pointed out you
know the um the group of Engineers and
scientists in the 1954 Dartmouth summer
workshop they said that they would
create AGI in in that summer yeah right
and and subsequently in the intervening
times people have said oh you know we'll
create this AGI architecture and I have
this component and this component and
there's a real anthropocentric bias here
first of all that we see capabilities
that don't exist in current models you
know and and also this extrapolative
fallacy that well it has these
capabilities already and if we add these
additional modules and components then
we'll just look at the difference
between monkeys and humans that's what
Connor said so the inference is well if
we add a few more modules and and
nodules into this language model then
could you imagine how far just
extrapolate on and the gradient is so
steep that we can't risk doing this
incrementally like there's all of these
like little little leaves that they make
yeah and you know the leap I think it's
three times isn't it the difference
between chimp brain and and human brain
but then three times greater than a
human brain you get an African elephant
so I mean I'm sure I'm sure you know
those arguments to be said larger brain
size is more capable that's for sure but
look at an octopus I mean that's
amazingly intelligent in its own domain
and its own understanding of the
environment
um which has a very small brain I think
sort of on the scale of um I think it's
half the size of something like an
ostrich brain which is incredibly stupid
um so you know we've got a sort of
be very wary where we're interpolating
and where we're definitely extrapolating
yeah um and I go back to the previous
example which is you know what does it
look like for AGI to get to the moon
what does that mean does it do we mean
that AGI has to without any human
um involvement build a Rockets
understand how to get that rocket to the
moon move itself what does that mean yes
so yeah
um there's a you know it's very easy to
talk very broadly about these ideas but
I think the detail is is where the
whether where the future lies I always
say that the future might be many many
things but one thing we can be for sure
that is going to be is detailed so we
might as well talk about the detail yeah
and not spend too long on the broad
broad stuff yeah I think that the final
result as well of this was that the con
side swung slightly to the to the to the
left or as in like the the contact
slightly one I think by about three or
four percent of movement yeah but
although tegmark would respond saying
that you know the big result was that so
many people already naively thought
naively or not depending how you look at
it thought that AGI was a risk yeah
exactly so yeah it's hard to say who
wins and loses I think what's
interesting is that it didn't move that
much
um and that yeah so that kind of shows
the entrenchment yep chose the
entrenchment but also shows that
broadbrush doesn't really get you very
far and that you need to to convince
people you need to talk talk about
details otherwise the same high level
ideas will still be true at the end of
the debate as they were at the start
because the weird thing though is that
in this particular case
um the the Layman already agrees with
the pro side but if it were the other
way around they would presumably make
the argument that the Layman was just
incapable of understanding the risk
yeah um yeah I suppose uh I think again
it's very
um it's very appealing the argument at a
high level and I think most people will
understand the principle that
super intelligence is
is a is potentially bad in future if it
can do things like self-replicate and
reason and we're hearing through the
media that it can do these things like
it can reason and there's this new thing
called chat GPT that you know has all of
this emerging capability so it's not
surprising to me that you know so many
people are putting together pieces very
sort of in a logical way that if we've
got a very intelligent system that can
self-replicate that that is potentially
bad and I don't think it I mean it helps
um when you know lacun says part way
through this debate that intelligence is
inherently good
um and that it's again just playing
straight into the hands of the the
opposition in this case to say that
because of course like you can end up
with intelligent people who want to do
bad things and so again that doesn't
particularly sort of strengthen the
argument I think but yeah it's
interesting to see so many people you
know their gut feeling about this seems
to be to be extremely worried
um but perhaps that just says something
about us as a society that we want to
kind of fear the worst and there's
something quite sort of
um
alluring about these doomsday scenarios
that sort of gets people you know really
truly believing in them yeah and I mean
maybe you can just comment on that just
the incredible shift of the Overton
window you know like new bad news
travels faster and there's something
really sticky about this I mean it seems
very orchestrated as well but um why do
you think that is
um I think first of all it's a much
easier position to take to be on the
side of the X risk because it's very
hard to prove you wrong
um the only way really to prove somebody
like that wrong is to absolutely
categorically prove that there's zero
risk
um which obviously you can't do you
can't prove the absence of something
there's even a section of the debate
where they talk about a teapot between
the orbits of
um uh Jupiter and Saturn and the fact
that it's very easy to prove something
like that would exist but how would you
possibly disprove it and um it's the
same thing here really it's the same
idea that to
to say yes there is of course a
potential for existential risk is very
different from saying there is an
existential risk and we need to pour a
huge amount of time and money into
solving it
there's it like is I totally agree with
what you said earlier which is that it's
a it's a gradation from narrow AI which
is what we've got at the moment and two
super intelligent AGI and we're
somewhere along that Spectrum certainly
gbt4 pushes us more towards generalist
zero shot learning and few short
learning
um but that to make it a debate which is
a completely black and white scenario as
to whether
something along this spectrum will be at
some point in the future and existential
risk is just so broad that it's almost
impossible to prove the opposite
um and so I think this is why you're
seeing a lot of people coming out and
saying yep because
the the counter argument is such a a
tiny kind of um part of this whole idea
space that they're positing that the
debate around that it's um
yeah you you really have to have thought
the arguments through to sort of come to
the conclusion as I would have done it I
would have been on the con side that
under my grounds for what I consider to
be existential risk that I would argue
more in favor of com than Pro here
because I don't see it as particularly
beneficial to see something as
existential risk in the near term and I
also don't think that it's likely given
the amount that we're missing
um yeah yeah and of course tegmark would
um probably argue that absence of
evidence isn't evidence of absence yeah
exactly
um so I I just I just think we have to
be really careful when talking about
this that we narrow down the field of
the debate or the discussion to a
particular mechanism
firstly I would recommend that secondly
I would say it's very important as well
to put some form of time frame and I'm
not it's not about saying like let's
make this really tightly scoped to three
years but but let's not go beyond like
you know 100 years because I feel like
you know this is this is broadly what
we're talking about here we're talking
about something that in our lifetimes is
going to cause us huge harm
um
and then also just kind of you know the
idea that we can actually start to prove
some of the ideas this doesn't have to
be a philosophy philosophical debate for
long we can build models that are
trained on limited amounts of data up
until a point in time and prove whether
what they can do in in terms of future
knowledge
um we can use problems like Arc to as a
basis for for testing these models and
and not just talk speculatively about
super intelligence or smarter than us at
the broadest level yeah we can actually
start to narrow down particular problems
but we already know the answer to that
we know that Arc hasn't been solved and
we know that if we I mean if we trained
a language model on 1930s data and to
see if it could discover relativity
um I don't think they would argue that
it could I mean obviously it can't yeah
yeah I think they're arguing that you
know with a few modules maybe it could
in the future
yeah maybe I mean I think I mean you
look at the experiments that would
ultimately to prove that and it was
things like measuring the eclipse and
the position of um Mercury behind the
eclipse and you know these are all
things that were carried out in the
physical world they weren't things that
a large language model could have
established for itself to be true
um and this is where you know just
cycling back right to the beginning of
the discussion
the idea of embodiment or as I like to
call it just physical
um physical presence is important
doesn't mean a body in the traditional
sense but it certainly means being able
to run experiments in the real world and
I don't think that's something that
um yeah getting getting feedback getting
from the physical world right yeah
exactly feedback yeah
um is important and it's not talked
about enough I think and I would
certainly be more scared for example if
these you know AGI systems of the future
were being put into highly Advanced
forms of robots where they were robust
to physical changes like knocking them
over doesn't knock them out they can
um you know they have extremely long
battery life or they have the ability to
kind of uh
um yeah to kind of you know recharge
themselves or whatever it might be in a
way that's robust to again changes in
the environment but um it feels like
we're a long way off that and that's not
something we need to be imminently
scared of in the in the in the slightest
David Foster it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you for double works mlms
too yeah this has been amazing yeah if
you folks like gogglebox mlst then we'll
get David back and we'll do another one
so I've really enjoyed this it's been
amazing thank you cheers amazing cool